Code reviews are an effective technique for detecting defects in artifacts.
Collected data indicates that for typical formal review, as described above,
between 70 and 90% of defects are found. That is,
if we're talking about a code review of all the defects in that code,
the review meetings are going to find between 70 and
90% if you have effective reviews. Of course, there is a cost which amounts,
in typical situations, to between 10 and 20% of the total cost of development.
This cost is largely due to the staff time involved in the preparation work and
the review meting itself. The above data notwithstanding,
defect detection rates vary dramatically depending on the specific rule goals,
artifact complexity and how effective the meanings are themselves.